today my talk is gonna be about
decentralized artificial intelligence
aka what happens when we take the two
hottest technologies of today AI and
blockchain and put them together rights
just sprinkle everything on top of each
other right so let's get right on into
this we've got a lot to cover so machine
learning AI this has been around since
the 50s it's not a new technology it's a
pretty old technology but basically the
idea has always been the same we have
some datasets right some input data set
and we have some objective we have
something that we want the AI to do in
this case classify a car is it a car or
is it not a car so what we do is we feed
this AI a bunch of images of cars so
think of it like an Excel spreadsheet
with two columns and column one you just
have pictures of cars and call them two
you just have labels car car car car or
cooker car right and so the idea is that
the AI learns the mapping the
relationship between the input data and
the output labels there is some
relationship between everything there is
a function in life for everything but
that's that's a bit of a tangent the
idea though is that the human would have
to extract all the features of what it
means to be a car right this is kind of
what a car looks like this is the shape
of a car this is what the exhaust pipe
looks like this was a very tiring
process but this is what humans had to
do
we'd extract features by hand and so
what happened is once we've extracted
those features we would feed it to some
kind of machine learning model and
there's a lot out there eventually it
would learn the mapping and then give it
a new car picture and it would know hey
this is a car but a few years ago there
was a scientist who said let me take one
specific machine learning model called a
neural network and sure drop the beat
right drop the mic and feed it lots of
data and lots of computing power and add
a lot of layers deep layers aka deep
learning that's what we call it what
happened is when we did this it started
outperforming every other machine
learning model and now deep learning is
the hottest topic in machine learning
it is outperforming everything else
self-driving cars drug discovery
everything hot that you're hearing about
AI is coming from deep learning okay so
that was my one slide overview of AI so
now blockchain right so a couple years
ago there was a programmer
who no one knows named Satoshi Nakamoto
who released a paper on a cryptography
mailing list detailing a system called
Bitcoin that allows two people to
transmit value online without needing a
third party namely a bank so what
happens is instead of a bank being the
third party there are a group of people
called miners and anybody can become a
miner you just need a laptop right
anybody can become a miner and the idea
is that when I transmit value to you
from me these miners have to approve
this transaction they to say okay let me
check this list of transactions so every
miner has a copy of every transaction
that has occurred in the network and
they have to approve whether or not this
transaction is valid or not right
because they have the list so you might
be thinking wait a second couldn't
someone just fake just create a bunch of
accounts and say hey I'm the majority of
the miners because the majority of the
miners have to approve a transaction for
it to be added to this list of
transactions well no because Satoshi
said every single miner has to prove
that they have solved some random
mathematical problem it's called the
proof of work algorithm and that means
that you have to have more computing
power than the 500 fastest
supercomputers in the world
combined to have the majority of the
computing power in the Bitcoin network
and because no one has that much
computing power no one's been able to
hack Bitcoin and that's why it has a
over 100 billion market cap as of
yesterday more than the GDP of some
countries and no one's been able to tack
it it's been around for a decade it's a
really powerful technology let's keep
going here but the really really
interesting part about Bitcoin is not
the actual application but the
underlying data structure of Bitcoin so
this is kind of a rough diagram of what
it looks like very simplified but the
idea is that we have some lists of
transactions right I'm talking about
this list of transactions that all of
the miners are holding and we group
these transactions together into little
groups that we call blocks and each
block points to the next block so one
block is like okay I'm Alyssa
transactions here's a next law and
that's like oh thanks for that okay
here's an list on the next block right
and it becomes this kind of chain a
blocks okay a blockchain right so it's a
blockchain that's what we call this data
structure and because of the
proof-of-work
algorithm no one can modify it it's an
unalterable
immutable in computer science terms
shout out to all the programmers out
there it's an immutable data structure
that no one owns and this is a very
powerful idea so I like to call this the
yin and the yang of AI and blockchain
right these two technologies go really
well together but no one's really put
them together yet so this is a very
futuristic thing so the yen is AI AI is
probabilistic it's all about computing
the likelihood that something will
happen the prediction of the future
using what it's learned and an AI is
always changing its updating its weights
it's learning about the future and an AI
is a set of algorithms that guess at
reality the yang part our block chains
block chains are not probabilistic they
are deterministic you know exactly
what's gonna happen right there are
permanence they are unchangeable and
they are algorithms and cryptography to
record reality so these two things can
go really well together if you break
them down into what they're really good
at so we live in a world where we are
all using these services right and these
services collect and monetize our data
that's the business model but this is a
problem because our data is the most
valuable thing we have and it will
become more valuable as everything is
slowly automated your data will be the
only agency that you have it will be
your most valuable asset so you need to
own it but right now we're giving it
away for free in return for a free
service ideally these services would be
paying us for our data right but that's
just not the case right now we need to
redo all of these apps that we have in
web 2.0 everything from eBay to Hoover
to lift all of it Facebook right morally
speaking this is a terrible idea to let
some humans control our data in the case
of Facebook they modified the newsfeed
to affect large swathes of the populace
and the 2016 political elections for
example in the US it's just it's just
very corrupt it's just not a good system
and not even talking about it morally
speaking let's talk about it technically
speaking centralized systems are not
good take the case of self-driving car
network let's say we've got three
self-driving cars at an intersection
okay three of them at an intersection
and they're dependent decide who has the
right-of-way but if there was one
central server that they all had to talk
to a million miles or
away then it would take forever and
there would be there would probably be
an accident ideally these cars could
talk to each other without needing a
third party or a central service or a
server so both technically speaking and
morally speaking creating what are
called decentralized applications is a
really good idea and it's what we call
as developers web 3.0 and that's what's
happening now if you're looking for
something to disrupt you take blockchain
you take AI you combine it together and
you create apps that have never before
been possible and that's the most
exciting thing these days so this leads
us to this idea it's a very abstract
idea but it's starting to happen of what
are called decentralized autonomous
organizations or dowse for short you can
also call them gaps decentralized apps
but the idea is that these are apps that
are run and maintained by the community
that uses them right so think of uber
for example when I am a writer and I'm
trying to find a driver I have to use a
third party namely uber to find that
driver and so uber takes a cut of this
and they have a bunch of malpractice as
well that we all know through all of
their scandals but ideally I wouldn't
have to trust Huber I could just find my
driver he would get paid more I would
have to pay less because there's no
third party so it would be better for
both of us
right we would all earn some equity
because we are all a part of the network
it's not just about earning money we'd
also earn equity and we would be able to
decide on the features of the app so we
would be a more democratic process right
it's it's kind of like a community owned
grocery store for example instead of one
central central person owning it
everybody who is a part of the network
would also be a participant in the
infrastructure of that network as well
so there's a lot of good that can come
from this there's a lot of good that can
come from this and that's what we're
gonna start to see as we move towards
web 3.0 if you're looking for a really
hot idea something really cool to do
this is it blockchain AI combine them
together use this immutable ledger and
have an AI live on the blockchain or at
least speak to the blockchain and data
is being pointed to to some distributed
hash table or some kind of decentralized
storage source and then there's a hope
there's a hole token model I've only got
two and a half minutes so I can't
explain it
everything here but there's there's so
much there's so much that's that's what
I'm trying to say but it's not all good
there's also bad I can't talk about the
good without talking about the bad right
so imagine this what you're seeing here
is a picture of art that was completely
generated by AI there is no human in the
loop so imagine an AI that lives on a
blockchain and its job is to just
generate art so what it does it does
this it generates some art it then sells
it on some marketplace it earns some
money
it uses that money to feed itself more
computing power it uses that computing
power to then to then generate more art
it just keeps amassing wealth and no one
can shut it down because it lives on a
blockchain right no one can shut it down
you'd have to have more computing power
than the 500 fastest supercomputers in
the world combined to shut it down
eventually it becomes the wealthiest
entity on the planet right so that's
kind of scary if you think about it it's
an unkillable AI and it lives on a
blockchain so how do we stop this wait
our responsibility as developers as
people people who don't even program to
educate ourselves on how this
intelligence works and only then will we
will be be able to stop any kind of
malpractice any kind of bad scenario
right the will of the collective will
override anyone bad actor so we have to
educate ourselves be more aware one
resource for this is my youtube channel
but the Internet is your university so
it's your responsibility to use it as
such I'm gonna end this talk with a rap
about decentralized AI so I want
everybody to stand up cuz I know you
guys are sleepy I know there's been some
sleepy speakers so please stand up
everybody all right everybody stand up
it's a it's a rap it's called smarter
it's a play on words it's a parody of
Kanye West stronger so I want you to put
your hands up in the air as well so
let's just go let's go I've got to read
papers to try and make me smarter I
trained my models in the cloud now
because my laptop takes longer I parse
through data like a boss now back then
my code was ronger subscribe if you want
to learn now let's spread this AI power
let's trade it right now let's train it
right let's make BOTS tonight and make
music like Mozart tonight and pay our
work on a cross tonight I've waited for
the software all my life just give it
some data and watch it explorers step
back clap and give it encore
he trained on 40 cores it's racer make
GPUs anymore
a game bought started off aimless but
now it's like God in the matrix my
chatbot speaks once I train it I work so
damn hard to make this it'll generate
words that it predicts and all I said to
MIT then tested this step is the [ __ ] to
invest in new data wizard training
contestant come in I got to read papers
to try and make me smarter I train my
models in the cloud now cuz my laptop
takes longer I parse through data like a
boss now back then Marcos was wrong er
subscribe if you want to learn now let's
spread this alright everybody thanks so
much
[Applause]